lamont-doherty Earth Observatory of
Columbia University has for nearly 65
years been located on a rather remote
campus of the University across the
Hudson across the George Washington
Bridge 18 miles from Morningside one of
the first things I did when I arrived at
Lamont was to convene a strategic
planning committee
I asked 12 of our top scientists to
gather information from the whole
scientific community and come up with
the top priorities for the research
directions that Lamont should be
pursuing over the next five to ten years
we're a very large organization
addressing the planet Earth from all of
the scientific perspectives by which we
can study our environment and the
interactions of the solid planet the
oceans the atmosphere how they work
together to form the climate how life
evolved on this planet and modified its
environment as it did so how the
environment impacts life and at Lamont
we have people who travel the globe they
say along every see they Trek deep into
the hearts of all of the continents we
have people working in the Arctic and
the Antarctic this is an earth
observatory because we emphasize the
gathering of global information and the
integration of that information into
ever more sophisticated models to try to
understand how our planet works this is
an era when the recognition that very
large data sets are important and there
are scientific clues to be gleaned from
mining combinations of large data sets
and Lamont is taking a leadership role
in integrating many large datasets that
heretofore had been
limited to principal investigators
laptop and and hadn't been generally
accessible so we've got a large group
that is making global datasets
manageable making global set datasets
accessible to the community in
geochemistry and petrology and marine
geology and geophysics and so we're
always wrestling with questions of
computational capability data volumes
but it's it's driving our science and
the opportunities to make advances in an
integrated view of the earth to see how
the different earth systems interact
demands that we be in a position to
extract as much as possible from these
huge global data sets so this is very
much at the forefront of our thinking
we're delighted that Columbia is is
pioneering some new directions in Big
Data when we feel that Earth Science has
a critical role to play in the future
ways of dealing with large datasets and
we're eager to contribute to say that we
understand our own planet demands that
we understand how all earth-like planets
formed and evolved so that the
particular aspects of our own planets
history that made our environment what
it is today
can be more deeply understood so for me
coming to Lamont first of all is coming
home to earth science secondly it's
bringing all the lessons that we learned
from other examples of earth-like
planets in the solar system to our own
planet and third it's an extraordinarily
interesting time in the earth sciences
because of the growing awareness of all
the changes going on the need to
understand those changes and the
opportunity to make a difference in
all of the ways that society is going to
have to address the way our planet is
evolving